it does look like at least some Republican
senators are going to do the right thing and
they're going to vote to have key witnesses
like John Bolton testify in the Senate impeachment
trial.
You'll remember we talked about it earlier,
earlier already in the context of the propaganda
war that is being waged at the start of Donald
Trump's Senate impeachment trial, Republicans
were able to get an absolutely ridiculous
decision to talk about subpoenaing witnesses
and documents and audio visual records after
both sides have had their 24 hours to present
their cases and possibly even after, uh, eat.
There have been 16 hours of questions from
senators.
This makes no sense knowing which documents
will be introduced.
Knowing which witnesses will testify would
be hugely important to structuring your case
as would be done in any other kind of trial.
But this is what Republicans were able to
pull off.
Good for them, I guess.
Although it's completely ridiculous.
So soon this is going to become the subject
in the Senate.
We know that you need only a simple majority
to subpoena witnesses, meaning the 45 Democrats,
the two independent senators who caucus with
Democrats.
That's 47 and four Republicans.
It seems that we have a couple of Republicans
that are going in the direction of at least
voting to subpoena John Bolton to testify.
Uh, one of those individuals is Utah Republican
Senator Mitt Romney.
Mitt Romney spoke to reporters and said he
has yet to decide, but he does seem to be
leaning in that direction.
It's increasingly apparent that it would be
important hear from John Bolton.
Uh, I of course will make a final decision
on witnesses after we've heard from not only
the prosecution but also the defense.
But I think at this stage it's pretty fair
to say that, uh, John Bolton has a, uh, relevant,
uh, testimony.
I think it's increasingly likely that other
Republicans will, uh, will join those of us
who think we should hear from John Bolton.
This came right after the New York times published
those excerpts from John Bolton's upcoming
book.
His manuscript of the book were Bolton destroys
every single talking point in the defense
of Donald Trump on the Ukraine issue.
John Bolton, very plainly and clearly saying
in his upcoming book, Trump told him withhold
the military aid to Ukraine until they smear
Joe Biden publicly.
This testimony would be devastating to the
Republican narrative and to Donald Trump's
narrative and we're going to talk more about
what that testimony might do in a little bit.
We also heard from Senator Susan Collins,
Susan Collins, Republican Senator from Maine.
She often is very concerned about something,
but then ends up voting with Republicans.
She put out a statement where she said from
the beginning, I've said that in fairness
to both parties, the decision on whether or
not to call witnesses should be made after
both the house managers and the president's
attorneys have had the opportunity to present
their cases.
She's wrong about that.
The decision should be made earlier, but okay,
this is her position going on to say, I've
always said that I was likely to vote to call
witnesses just as I did in the 1999 Clinton
trial.
The reports about John Bolton's book strengthen
the case for witnesses and have prompted a
number of conversations among my colleagues.
So that's potentially two Republicans who
will join the Democrats and independents that
would make 49 votes.
You still need two more to get to the 51 that
are needed.
But increasingly there are rumblings that
there will be four, at least four Republicans
who vote to subpoena John Bolton.
Now, even if John Bolton shows up, you aren't
going to get a conviction of Donald Trump,
but that's not relevant.
Now, we knew that going in and exposing what
John Bolton has to say to the widest possible
audience, once again, confirming the brazen
nature of Donald Trump's lies would be a very
good thing.
There's always a risk that Republican senators
will say, I lean towards testifying or whatever,
and then they don't actually vote for it.
In the end, Susan Collins has done that many
times.
Go back to the cabinet hearings until they
actually vote.
I will assume nothing of them.
Um, but it looks like this may actually become
a reality.
John Bolton's testimony, Romney politically
would suffer no consequences from his vote.
By the way, Mitt Romney could get reelected
indefinitely in Utah as long as he wants,
no matter what he does.
As many of you know, Utah has a large Mormon
population.
Mitt Romney is Mormon.
Utah is also very conservative.
Mitt Romney has that seat for essentially
as long as he wants it.
Hopefully he's not just saying he'd consider
voting that way.
And actually we'll, we've, we've been disillusioned
before.
We've seen Mitt Romney and Susan Collins,
sometimes Lisa Murkowski, they pretend to
have a spine.
They pretend to have morals.
They say they're very worried and then they
just vote with Republicans.
So we'll believe it if and when we see it,
it will do nothing to secure votes for the
conviction of Donald Trump from Republicans.
Remember that I just don't trust them.
And anything that depends on a few Republicans
acting appropriately, we've learned over the
last 20 years.
It's just not something we can count on in
American politics.
But let's now get to the effect of the Bolton
testimony because Republicans are panicking
about what that possible testimony could mean.
And could cause.
So let's
talk about
that next.